we're going in like [ __ ] marines you
understand me welcome to church
[ __ ]
[Music]
hey let me tell you something lee
[Music]
get up [ __ ] it's all over
listen we had a rough couple of months
[ __ ] katrina's cousin maria
the other one puerto rico houston
[ __ ] florida listen it's been tough
up to now the earthquake in mexico
you know the white house whoever the
[ __ ] is going on
but it don't matter
they want to shoot it's time for us to
[ __ ] shoot duck suckers they want to
get down and dirty
don't forget who the [ __ ] we are you
understand me we're the baddest
[ __ ] out there you send the
message to that [ __ ] north korean
he's going to be sniffing my dick and
sucking my [ __ ] that's the focus
we're going to north korea like a year
it's going to be an island it's going to
glow in the dark you know why because
we're americans [ __ ] who the [ __ ]
do you think you're dealing with
stop with the gun control they're
selling more guns than that for the last
three days
stop with the [ __ ] whining
stop with the russians on facebook i
don't give a [ __ ] worry about yourself
keep your eyes open and get the [ __ ] off
snapchat and [ __ ] twitter
stay black
i know i gotta go to bed where you going
i got a [ __ ] early workout class
tomorrow joey ct scan hey for those of
you to wear me out for every time you're
on a cleanse you're drinking water with
garlic get it every time you come you
come with something
come when you're drinking i want you to
be festive i'm gonna i'm gonna hey
that's next week i'll come back next
week all of a sudden you're taking my
shirt then you should have told me joey
i can't go tonight because i gotta take
an insurance thing
he's gonna eat a [ __ ] trouble by
himself you know yeah poorly we're
looking forward to you know for you get
[ __ ] up go on the bicycle and get hit
i told him when i started working out i
was gonna get a bike and he said no and
then he called me back like 20 minutes
and he's like let me explain myself
these idiots let me explain myself
these indians can't drive normally now
you're gonna bike you're gonna get
[ __ ] hit and then we can't do the
podcast i'm gonna be at the hospital
we're gonna do the podcast so you can't
ride a bike so when he told me you're
gonna bike here i'm like oh no
because i knew i he hates bikers it
makes me [ __ ] nervous man i want you
to head up on the skateboard
hey for those of you asking when i said
i was making twelve hundred dollars a
week doing stand up and saying it wasn't
much money you're forgetting to
incorporate that we have to pay agents
taxes managers
flights and our plan tickets so it
whittles down to you should know how
little 750 bucks come turns out oh no
a business you just pick me up when i
would work i like my last job i was
making 1300 a week
and by the time taxes got done it was
900. and i can't imagine that was just
enough to pay like my bills i can't
imagine having a wife and two kids well
and then agents and managers you're
talking about 35 right off the top right
off the top it's gone yeah and then
you're talking about another 50 or 30
percent of for taxes whatever whatever
uh are you going to this tour now
yeah i'm gonna go down there [ __ ] around
and uh do my spot and bomb but i'm
getting stronger every day
i don't give a [ __ ] bro
last night he was amazing are you around
next week yeah
once yeah let's do a problem let's do my
house i'll do all over your house
we'll bring the flying
juice
but we gotta eat this one today no no i
want to see you guys kill it no why
would he do that look at how [ __ ]
lucid joey is look at me yeah well
that's joey let's see the novel no
that's finished
why don't you finish it because he's got
the i got the [ __ ] ct scan and the
[ __ ] life insurance [ __ ] let's go
for it no i can't i can't have any more
guys go home you go home
that's it it's not the fact that i'm
going no no no no no
no no no that's so i'm so good already
let's do another half and all you've
done is one you did one whole one i did
[ __ ] one and a half two you're gonna
leave me like this what are you saying
i'm gonna leave you like that i need for
you too because i'm already
too high so what i need for you to go
into that michael jackson zone you know
and die
you can't die from it you can't die from
it the only way weed can kill you is if
you shot out of a cannonball that's out
of a cannon
i'll smoke i'll smoke
this smells [ __ ] delicious private
reserve private reserve and [ __ ]
sunset they're good
that good dog there's some good [ __ ]
that place in san diego that sent this
weed with jessica all right that alpha
plane that had some prior reserve they
were good too they got some good weed
out there but you gotta get let's kill
this out of respect
i'm gonna kill the let's kill it you can
go right home jews don't believe in in
the devil yes they do they are the devil
you [ __ ] jew [ __ ] [ __ ] i love you
bert christian thank you very much for
coming thank you
i love you guys with all my have a great
weekend we will be back monday night or
whatever we don't [ __ ] know yet till
next week who gives a [ __ ] have a great
weekend stay black uh tomorrow's a tough
day for our country today's a tough day
for our country it is what it is we're
american [ __ ] as a matter of fact the
national anthem oh boy let's go we're
going to open up with the national item
player that's true
and no [ __ ] [ __ ] the harps and
people said no i got it saved yeah i
want the good [ __ ] not neil diamond
are you ready let's do this it's
september 11th people
[Music]
it's september 11th
i know 10 12 years ago we had disaster
and these [ __ ] momos were walking
around what are we gonna do terrorist
the only [ __ ] terrorist is the fear
you have of yourself we're [ __ ]
americans you take that plane to hit the
world trade centers and you stick that
up somebody's [ __ ] [ __ ] we're
americans [ __ ] don't you ever [ __ ]
forget that that means we do what the
[ __ ] we want to do
we're americans [ __ ] isis [ __ ]
terrorists [ __ ] turbans [ __ ] everybody i
hate all you [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] americans that means
nobody [ __ ] stops us we want our
dicks up we get our dicks up that's what
an american does ask the [ __ ]
pilgrims [ __ ] 911.
[ __ ] 911 it'll never happen again
we're
you don't ever have to be afraid again
[ __ ] obama [ __ ] them all
we're americans you son of a [ __ ] grab
your guns go shoot somebody
[Music]
i
oh my goodness
where's the music oh [ __ ] i forgot this
christ almighty i'm [ __ ] saying
get up [ __ ] salute the flag get
up everybody get up it's memorial day
weekend i'm sure you had a grandpa who
killed a japanese person
i'm sure you had an uncle who stabbed
the puerto rican in the heart something
get up it's not about potato salads and
cheeseburgers you [ __ ]
it's about being a [ __ ] american a
state of mind you need to be born in
america to be an american just need to
get up in the morning grab your balls
and look at the flag and look at jesus
and say you know what i got this [ __ ]
suckers i don't need no [ __ ] welfare
check i'm a savage all i need is a
[ __ ] knife a spear and a f i don't
even know what i need no more you know
what i'm saying it's sunday special
edition memorial day weekend get your
[ __ ] together it's like whatever i don't
there's a comedy show called the
degenerates of comedy you did it why did
they call like
did any of the comics get offended you
called us degeneres we are for the most
part we are
we're [ __ ] animals on the road for
them i mean i can't say that about women
all the time because like we're on the
road a little bit more nervous than a
male comic of course 10 times over and
it's still a bar it's a bar it's a night
club
they're partying
it still doesn't matter
it doesn't excuse what i did next week
and it's not going to excuse what's
about to happen in the next couple weeks
because they made a lot of calls
and you know what
i didn't get one [ __ ] call you know
why because i wouldn't push a negative
narrative and that's what they want they
want anything
negative they want anything negative you
know i would love i wish people address
it you know in the right way
i haven't remembered you know i had to
look back and go well
i think of a couple situations one of
one which i spoke with the podcast i'm
not going to tell the name to give you
ammunition
i spoke to a person i had a problem with
when i first met her
we were doing a couple lines of coke and
i told her she had nice titties
and she played it off like you know
nobody's ever told me this before you're
a pig really
well oh i love shock i love this is what
i know about you yeah and a couple weeks
later i go to a party and i see it with
somebody and it's like
you were trying to play [ __ ] virgin
mary
and you got busted i'm not afraid of him
but i that's what i'm saying like
everybody right now feels like they're
all in shock like oh my god what happens
at nightclubs oh my god what does comics
talk dirty comics embellish [ __ ] you
emails that would
it would make you [ __ ] i will be
listen i will be
not one person has called me about
anything from the comedy store and i've
been there for calling anybody who
matters well but here's the thing i've
been there from i don't have any credits
like that everybody who
i mean i've heard in these articles and
these interviews that adam's name has
come up and i don't know why this is
crazy
has come up who's the sweetest guy in
the world adam r adams
what did you call him adam angle i don't
[ __ ] let him eat
ebay just call me ebay i don't know how
many people's names have come up that
i've said
what are you talking about why is his
name because if he it
here's the thing like back in the day
girls will come up to me and be like how
do i get spots how do i get spot how do
i get a showcase how do i get whatever
it was like whether they were past and
not getting spots or whether they were
trying to get past right because both
happen when you can get past like mitzi
said she would be like ugh i made a
mistake on that after i saw him and
she'd stop giving them spots one person
one guy got really pissed off and went
to mitzi and was like why am i not
getting spots and she goes okay i'll
have you reshowcase and then she
unpassed that [ __ ] for making
him sit making her sit through that and
it was the only person i ever saw her do
that too but it made me laugh so i would
immediately tell people don't
talk to mitzi if you've been past
here's little tricks you can do like and
it was something as simple as send scots
and tequila or wine
yeah i would tell people all the time
send cigarette whatever it was that the
the town coordinator could casually
bring your name up in front of mitzi and
spark her memory whether it good or bad
it'll work and it did so then people
would say how can i get spots should i
[ __ ] this guy this guy told me if i blow
him that he'll help me and i go
who would help you if you know he's
going to come and forget you and i go if
you want to know who to [ __ ] to get into
the club if it's not mitchy sure you're
doing it wrong because she's the only
one that can put you on stage up until
she got real real sick and tommy started
there was one time when me and corey one
week where mitzi was real sick in the
late 90s
and she was
she went to get stem cell injections i
think bob uh wheeler took her and she
was you know it was her first like bout
with this [ __ ] her sickness and so
she asked us to do the lineup and we
corey and i were devastated nervous
wreck we didn't want to hurt anybody's
feelings we love everybody so we copied
mitzi's format that was one week we
still weren't in charge of anything
really we just copied mitzi's format and
then if we joke about this all the time
or at least rick and i do on the comedy
store podcast how when she came back and
started doing it she literally would
just go to ace so the con it would be
like aaron cater a metamed like whoever
was [ __ ] ace got on the lineup
because she was getting her health was
declining so then tommy duncan
left tommy got in there and then once he
saw that she was really really declining
and he started doing the lineup he would
then unfortunately
[ __ ] with people and you know well you
know if you do this you know he had his
own narrative and his favorites were
whitney and crystalia and mitzi didn't
pass them tommy did
technically
like
whatever and because he saw
these are going to be the future or
whatever he saw something in them and he
was passing and he was a dick to a lot
of people he was but he was the town
coordinator and technically she gave him
the reigns to do that and the only other
person that had that was adam because he
was thrown into it but adam showcases
people he doesn't give sexual [ __ ]
favors for getting stage time and he
doesn't not give you stage time if you
didn't give him or
don't like him because i've had people
come up to me and be like he doesn't
like me he doesn't yeah he doesn't like
your stand-up
you're taking a personal like you you he
asked you out and you said no and now
you think that's why you're not getting
sick you're not funny you need to
[ __ ] reevaluate or
you could be funny but just maybe he
doesn't think you're funny enough for
the lineups he's putting together and if
you're [ __ ] hurt by that [ __ ] you i'm
sorry would you go to every casting
director and be like how did i not get
in this movie i'm perfect for it and
then just be like well b it's because i
i was supposed to go out with him or i
was supposed to go out with her and now
they're holding a grudge that's not how
it works
i don't i don't i'm rattling but i'm
pissed that's why you're absolutely
right because i'm pissed it's just
you're you're changing you're changing
the narrative first of all what with
what is going on with crystallia i'm
like i said i'm thrilled these girls
spoke up right and if he did something
bad that will [ __ ] come out it will
happen you will get your justice but
don't change it and take away from
something that needs to be dealt with
for real because you didn't get [ __ ]
spots at the comedy store stop it and
not one person has come to me and said
no that's not true because you know that
because they know i know the real truth
i i watched it even with adam i've been
doing stand-up for 13 years adam took
over
probably what uh six years ago seven
years ago six ish seven yeah so and he
was thrown into it reluctantly he did
not want to do this he did not want that
job nobody wants that [ __ ] job nobody
wants the job of telling you're good
enough to get on this lineup or you're
not man or woman and the other thing is
with the women they're trying to [ __ ]
men and women are all the same where
there is no gender but but then when
there's a [ __ ] problem all of a
sudden there's a gender right all of a
sudden these are males or monsters and
they're trying to hurt women and not all
male
males are [ __ ] i have six brothers
i would say
some of them are [ __ ] some of them
aren't you know whatever i
i'm flipping out because i just don't
know what i'm just happy that
you were there 97 to 2000
you witnessed me you witnessed me at my
lowest points on drugs yeah and to say i
[ __ ] my way in i've heard that one too
because i slept with dice that's my
second ex-fiance i wasn't even doing
stand-up when i was with dice and and
when i started doing stand-up
respectfully because he was a higher up
technically not because he's male just
because he's [ __ ] andrew dice clay
and he started at
the comedy store so when i started doing
it i called him and i called mitzi
because i have respect for them and i
didn't want them to think oh i'm [ __ ]
crazy i'm going to go there because i'm
dice's ex and i'm going to [ __ ] with him
and stay at the store or uh you know i'm
an ex-waitress and i want to [ __ ]
piss off mitzi by doing stand-up i
didn't do it for the wrong reasons i
called them to say hey i'm gonna try
this is this okay if i come to the store
i i asked permission and mitzi let me
she she told me to do the belly room uh
and i did and then she showcased i i
showcased three or three times for mitzi
it took me three years to get past
and i was her personal assistant i did
everything i went out of the country
with mitzi like we were tight
so and with andrew he took me on the
road
and i didn't do i got booed off the
stage and he put me in the [ __ ] back
burner for a year and then i had a
re-showcase for him so don't tell me i
didn't do the [ __ ] leg work and that
i [ __ ] my way into a comedy store
paint regular because i'll beat the [ __ ]
out of you one two
i worked my ass off for it
everything i got and and there's a lot
of women that they talk like that about
and one of them is
whitney cummings that came somebody said
it to me and i thought
[ __ ] you man we were in the same show
she said something to me worked every i
wake up and i say what would whitney do
that's how i [ __ ] think whether you
like her stand up or not do i think
whitney's the funniest person on the
planet no but i think she's [ __ ]
brilliant she puts her time in and she
puts her [ __ ] time in and bust her
goddamn ass she wasn't she was sleeping
with regular [ __ ] guys like the rest
of us nobody special i can think of four
four three different guys that she was
dating they were regular [ __ ] guys
they weren't they didn't have any power
she was just smarter than you and you
don't [ __ ] like it she said something
to me that made sense for you eliza
eliza too eliza's [ __ ] great allie
wong
leslie jones who the [ __ ] the leslie
[ __ ] leslie's phenomenal she said when
you come to this town you and you go to
the comedy store you have two decisions
you can either suck deck or put your
ponytail into the hat and become one of
the guys
yeah you've done that you're one of the
guys i've talked about why because you
had nine brothers
and you know exactly how they talk they
scratch their balls they sniff their
fingers they're monsters but i love it i
would tell you right in front of them
how they [ __ ] the neighbor in the ass
talk yeah
she was half [ __ ] [ __ ] if i set up
yeah
and you laughed a little bit but that
was what uh
you know that they said coursed
there was no need to coerce nobody
nobody co-hers these girls were willing
god bless me
i mean there was many others and i've
heard many other stories
and like i said i'm not here with this
podcast now the next step is where this
goes
where does this go if it goes any
further it's dumb i gotta be it's gonna
go further it's gonna go further well
they're gonna pick apart every person
anybody that's ever laughed at richard
pryor should be executed then he grew up
in a whorehouse
and that's how he saw women it's going
to go further and
at least for me it is uh
they made some calls
they called seattle let's see why i left
seattle
you know were they worried you have a
[ __ ] past you're pretty open about it
oh i am they're going after clubs for
certain reasons for not doing
i heard this in an email
a stricter background checks in the
comics to make sure that sexual
predators like now they have us they
have oh my gosh how the [ __ ] are we
gonna
prevent that about the wednesday i
celebrate 20 years with my girlfriend
when you saw us terry uh my girlfriend
that's your wife [ __ ]
in my head we've been together 20 years
wow
so you gotta remember when i started
dating terry i was still snorting coke
but i was at the store and i couldn't
really do nothing because now she'd know
it she was right there watching me yeah
so for you [ __ ] that want to
say something and terry don't [ __ ]
around jerry don't [ __ ] around terry was
the if i worked five nights
work she will do [ __ ] you up jack that's
my girl that's why i love terry like
terry worked five nights
all right i need a little national
anthem real quick today because there's
something we got to talk about
people are having do's and nots and what
we got to do some national anthem i
don't know any dates coming up
no you [ __ ] they canceled everything
no not till sep uh no i'm in um
when is it [ __ ] august 6 i'm at phoenix
at the house of comedy
august but that's not to august my july
date got cancelled in vancouver tweeted
and we'll retweet it i love it thank you
so much and uh no i'm happy to have you
on today because i wanna sorry if i went
off a little bit i don't decide you were
there okay you were there my wife was
there so listen
terry what the [ __ ] they gonna come up
with because i got a thousand stories i
got a million
dollars call me whatever story you want
to come up with there's got to be a back
end to it about six months ago i get
home way before cove in november okay
and some girl who lost you know what it
is she's a cute blonde girl
she was married to an owner of a comedy
club
and
i always considered her a dear friend i
saw her at the haha when i was trying to
make a comeback and i wasn't going to
the store
and one night i go on twitter on a
saturday it's gotta be 11 30 and i read
her tweet which says
joey once went into a bathroom in the
back of the bus while i was in the
bathroom
and i thought about it for a second and
i go holy [ __ ] that's right in 98
we were doing a roger paul gig
oh wow back at the bus and i had to go
to the bathroom
and when she found out i had packaged
she asked me if i'd do a package so
usually do a package in the bathroom so
i go you didn't mention we were doing
the package
you're just going to all of a sudden
that's what we're only going to put out
half the story everything's half the
[ __ ] story
so i was like [ __ ] you know [ __ ] this
[ __ ] and i wrote to have a package
so i know that
uh
you know what they're trying to leave it
out to make that
we got 20 years right here i got 20
years who i've been with at the house
my wife was a wages at the store
and she can attest to [ __ ] want to
raise your hand come on with it there
was a friend of ours who recently died a
big guy
his wife became a saint all of a sudden
she doesn't know no she's trash spitting
the grave before she also got smacked
around at the store yeah she got smacked
around a couple of places so far at a
race yeah but for me from me this time
but this this is the thing with terry
terry was there when we were all just so
you know the cesspool the comedy world
is and as night club becomes when you're
there all the time there was a part
where we had a herpes outbreak because
we were all [ __ ] each other and uh
i'm up well i wasn't really in that part
but i was in that and we all had to go
get tested for herpes and i don't want
this to reflect on the store or any
other place no no no i'm saying every
night club
yes
are we going to close every night club
love
there was a lot of love there there
still is a lot of love there
you know i feel bad for delia and all
this when we have to go back
but these stories we're talking about
change
oh yeah we'll be back no but i'm saying
this
they won't
they won't happen any they don't happen
as much as they used to because their
people don't realize the cameras at the
store you just can't get mitti was sick
she wasn't there she wasn't watching you
get [ __ ] up you get your suction store
now you pop up from somebody's zoom
while they took it to the grandmother
the final steps
kill martin god bless her lori
phenomenal diana colvin there you are
getting your dick sucked in the bathroom
in the main room
squirting in some girl's eyeball and
i'm telling you is there a napkin back
here and you're like nah
not really it's a linux
they got light bulbs though you want to
light up to wipe your eyeball with
any dates so you got june
july i mean uh july got cancelled i'm
sorry i'm at the house of comedy in
august i believe it's august 6th 7th and
8th i don't know let's keep your
[ __ ]
prayers open we got july 21st
at oxnard
uh that's where they'll start and then
hopefully july 29th
through august 1st in brea
if the covet disappears please if you
[ __ ] don't start marching
against something else next week
you know martian lives matter let's do
that one because the martian got [ __ ]
run over in new mexico
how about [ __ ] anything i didn't talk
about that joey don't joke about it i
heard you're being insensitive to
martians i know [ __ ] them too
all they've ever done is [ __ ] create
people to go crazy i saw marshall so
much him and bigfoot [ __ ] both
and uh i love you at all my heart i
appreciate the video i appreciate it
thank you thank you for people watching
because these [ __ ] obviously
don't know and number two let me explain
some to you hit me with the national
anthem
should i stand
uh
i feel like i have to stand
i got nervous i want to find no flutes
my daddy's a marine it's got american
flag on it that's the one
real quick know that lower that so i can
talk over this
get up you [ __ ] it's monday
the 30th whatever the [ __ ] it is of june
enough is enough already for three
months we've been living in [ __ ]
misery confusion we're broke
we're hungry we want [ __ ] answers
stop blaming china
stop it
stay in your house move out of that
[ __ ] apartment but most importantly
social distance and most importantly
besides that
this is a crucial [ __ ] situation and
some of you are not happy
put your [ __ ] mask on you [ __ ]
maggot [ __ ] let me tell you
something you think i like putting a
[ __ ] mask on i don't like putting the
mask on i gotta smell my own breath
50 years of rotten teeth and [ __ ]
and
[ __ ] [ __ ]
breath and [ __ ] nose hairs i don't
want smelling the [ __ ] breath either
but you have to do it why because we're
trying to keep each other alive how can
we be so [ __ ] selfish you know what
you want to go to the bar go [ __ ]
yourself go to the liquor store buy a
bottle like every other american and go
outside and get three or four of your
friends and get [ __ ] up no more
[ __ ] parties no more get-togethers i
don't want to see no black chicks
twinking with your ass up and down they
told you you can't eat ass and here you
are spreading those [ __ ] germs up in
the air
i feel bad for midgets you [ __ ]
filthy [ __ ] animals so do me one
favor whether you agree or disagree
when you're home when you're scratching
your balls
listen i wouldn't put a mask on either i
fought it and i could smell the fart
through the [ __ ] mask so if i could
fart and smell it through the mask
outside at the park that means you can
maybe get a little corona vibe no you
can't get the corona virus what i'm
telling you is it's a public [ __ ]
nuisance now pretty soon
people are gonna get stuck getting hit
in the head with [ __ ] karate elbows
and [ __ ] keep your mask on fourth of
july is coming do you want to be [ __ ]
caught up in the fourth of july where's
the music
where's the mule bubble started again
where's the music we're americans we
gotta [ __ ] join in now
and enough is enough put on your [ __ ]
mask it's not self-respect it's not
respect for us it's starting to be
respect for ourselves
i wear a map put it on more i want to
hear more i'm getting fired up here
don't make me [ __ ] get a bottle and
cut into that and make it chase
different directive epic [ __ ]
groups you understand me
get that mask put it on shut your
[ __ ] mouth
you [ __ ] little animals in miami you
[ __ ] jungle spanish people down there
you got you should wear a mask as day
one when i came from cuba they put a
mask and goggles on me that's how
contagious i was all right so go [ __ ]
yourself don't let me break out the
goggles you [ __ ] immigrant [ __ ]
you're lucky you're here put on a
[ __ ] mask
it's a [ __ ] right
and everybody else you [ __ ] white
people that think you're better than
everybody because you pay taxes and you
[ __ ] drive up a prius
so what go [ __ ] yourself put on your
mask
black people they're trying to kill us
put on your mask if it ain't a [ __ ]
cop it's a bullet now it's some chinese
doing a laboratory trying to kill you
and mexicans first of all if three is
over 200 pounds i don't want to say it
together every time i see seven fat
mexicans
covered is coming it took out a family
down in orange county if you're seven
that made mexicans and you're heavy
knock it off
invite three skinny cousins who just got
here and ran the three miles
no more than four fat mexicans can get
together and that's cuban salvadorans
you puerto ricans too you're not
excluded
you have black and you have spanish you
you guys that they roll the dice down
there in puerto rico put your [ __ ]
mask on
social distance and have a little
[ __ ] respect
you see a line [ __ ] six feet 10 feet
put on your mask i don't enjoy it either
look at me i look like a [ __ ] i look
like i just got out the [ __ ] uh
sucking 300 dicks is what you look like
when they throw you out what happened to
him they ran a train through him last
night at the gay bar with 300 dicks i
don't like wearing a mask
does it say in american constitution no
but right now as americans what's going
on and the numbers in florida
texas arizona and california
wear your [ __ ] mask
it's monday go out there and be a
[ __ ] champion the church what's
happening now thanks you i want to thank
eleanor kerrigan i want to thank [ __ ]
lee lee leland
and i want to thank you guys for all the
support of what's going on in each
other's lives you need comedy i got the
[ __ ] answer you understand me but it
all starts with the mask i don't give a
[ __ ] you're gonna hate me for this but
as part of the church us
we gotta be marines in this [ __ ] we put
on our mask
have a great week have a great monday
god bless you take this [ __ ] mu
lee get this [ __ ] mask off me oh
c-h-u-r-c-h in the box like a
[ __ ] and start with that 10
percent off you like the product they
have to stay on a product where they
send it right to your [ __ ] house
every month on the first you're gonna do
dick you know leave the house gonna
click on the page they'll send you the
hem protein to your house they'll send
you the alpha brain the house they'll
send you a shroom tech you'll be walking
around like coop could do you know what
i'm saying
who the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with here at least
i'm really hungry look at the what the
[ __ ] you are high dog 10 milligrams
at least give me the credit i deserve
that was like what 70.
it was 70 if we split it it's thirty you
look like a happy jacker
whatever tells you that that's how i
feel you weigh 35 milligrams okay
and the joint i got here this is east
bay grown somebody gave me a nice
present i forgot to call you and thank
you
i got the stuff in my wallet
i don't want to be rude i don't want to
be here love in vain you know what i'm
saying
like you're not high these people took
good care of me do you get hot how often
do you get highly
whenever i'm with him
he gets
to get high every day
he's got to go to that school here you
know this ain't no
this is what happens if the [ __ ] the
russians get you even they're gonna give
you a goulash
[ __ ] no
they're gonna make you smoke dope every
day and you're gonna be prepared they
can't trick you they'll try to tell you
a russian jew you're gonna tell them to
suck my dick and call me shorty i was
born in 1940. i don't know what what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
i know nothing all i know is still
maureen's birthday today do people know
that yeah
and that's how many years today i don't
know how many years you don't [ __ ]
know these people you the reason why
people really use your [ __ ] yarmulke
is because of the [ __ ] marines huh
and you don't know you got some pair of
balls
it's their birthday don't make me make
you get up and [ __ ] 239th birthday 239th
birthday defending this beautiful
[ __ ] country
i want to salute the marine corps or you
savages at your house keep stabbing
[ __ ] shoot him in the head take
that heroin do what the [ __ ] you got to
do you got one shot at being a [ __ ]
soldier you guys are out there who will
[ __ ] watch the judges who the [ __ ]
are we the judges these soldiers they're
[ __ ] marines 239 battalion and [ __ ]
don't make me go crazy and start
stabbing [ __ ] today
sam tripley what's going on with you i
know you had the cd
the cd went out just right
don't make me started oh [ __ ] there we
go
why you gotta do this i'm getting
emotional
the marines be all you can be
i salute you bad [ __ ] i salute
any of you in the armed forces the army
the navy the [ __ ] coast guard the air
force you're out there banging that [ __ ]
that's heavy who do you think goes down
first you old navy old navy i love you
as well
but happy birthday to the marines the
baddest [ __ ] out there
four [ __ ] servicemen were sitting
around a campfire one night
and they were telling stories
the guy in the army ranger was talking
about how he stabbed three puerto ricans
in the war of ouija me
the air force guy was talking about how
he shot down a bunch of [ __ ]
vietnamese [ __ ] [ __ ]
in the war of [ __ ] two fingers
and the navy
the seal he put explosives
and the whole time
the marine was staring the soup with his
dick
you understand that thing was boiling
and the marine was just staring at with
his dick
salute you happy birthday you bad
[ __ ] savages
that's how you do it you [ __ ] put
your heart on tape when you salute the
armed forces you think i'm gonna be one
of those momos at the airport saluting
them [ __ ] no they got the green suit on
they got chemical warfare
i keep [ __ ] walking
what the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with joey bananas on a monday night
you were sitting there watching some
monday night football like the step that
you are
you know i'm saying are you that [ __ ]
stoned why are you looking at me no no
no no no because i i i look at you you
you you seriously like you're somebody
that that i com i respect your opinion
right now obviously i've
well he's got the mexican dude with the
glasses in the car and he's about to cut
his fingers over
that's [ __ ] funny man
that's so [ __ ] funny man i'm sad
i worked with joe for [ __ ] 10 years
on the road
you know how many weekends here and
there
and you learn you learn
the character of a comic you learn the
evolution of a comic you learn
how the first cherokee's jumping up and
down
and everybody's drinking and now it gets
a little calmer but it's crazier in
another department you know what i'm
saying
and how tours change because there's
never really a tour it was an endless
tour yeah it was the never ending tour
the name would change but it was it was
it was like a like a like a 20-year
journey like i don't i mean
not quite 20 but i mean gabriel he just
what celebrated uh
yeah
through 20 years of his career and a lot
of it was spent you know i i'm you know
i shoot i was fortunate enough to see
a big portion of it you know from a very
uh early phase you know i mean he he
just i mean he blew up in front of us in
front of us really
you know we saw him go to another level
from
you know zero to a billion the bicycle
club on third on tuesday nights 35 hours
gonna pick it up on friday between four
and six that's when i want to go to the
[ __ ] 710
between four and six on a friday those
[ __ ] suckers
so it was crazy
that we got to see the hotels how they
changed yeah how it went from uh plane
to buses to your own personal bus to
maybe a private jet to maybe you know
uh from it wasn't delaware no more
philadelphia now you're going to [ __ ]
uh
europe and germany no seriously i went
from southwest airlines to to [ __ ]
private jets private jets yeah and and
sometimes not even southwest airlines
sometimes
driving in a car you know four people
deep
if it's to arizona or [ __ ] that's
right you know or two or two uh you know
bakersfield san francisco second home
yeah yeah guys
yeah we took we drove we drove we we it
wasn't always private place and in
retrospect i look at it yeah and it was
very much canister-ish without even
seeming kelly for this
you guys were all good friends
nobody was really going off to deep end
with cocaine or or uh you know shooting
heroin with hookers or
missing radio everybody's very
professional it was it was it was magic
but it was a different type of magic it
was a different type of magic i was at
the scene a few times yeah and i could
feel the love in the room you know
after the [ __ ] thing gabriel would go
eat
and dirty people you know i'm saying
everybody's eating like a [ __ ] king
and uh
people ask them for pictures i mean it's
a surreal world it really was it was to
be into to be a part of that world and
and and taste it you know um and at
whatever level it is you know there's
people that have come in and you know
done that gabriel's brought out on the
road for for certain gigs that see the
the magnitude because people if unless
you see it
it's really hard to know you can't
describe it without sounding kind of
like almost like you're boasting or
bragging or something but it's like i've
seen people like look at look at like
i've seen dude i've seen families
that'll say things like uh
you know
we just buried
our our such and such relative who was a
huge fan and we actually had his picture
of you it was like a shrine to him that
they buried this man with
you know and then they all like and then
they go to this place to eat out in the
middle of texas and in san antonio i
think we were and they run into gabe
right after like legit they're there for
dinner after they just buried this kid
you know and they see gabe and and
it might have been it's it was almost
like if you know like if jesus would
have walked in back in the day
by the way these people were looking to
see how a really good comic acts
yeah a really good comic uh
just the composure you know i got to
learn a lot from joe rogan guys a lot
on the road hoping for him you know i
added some things i would say listen why
are we doing this
why are we leaving at one and rocking
the whole day
let's put this together at eight get the
[ __ ] out of here early you know like
i would add some stuff and it all worked
and today that's what the system i use
today
i use the same [ __ ] system every week
i was never a gabriel's guy i really
like traveling alone most of the time to
be honest with you
i think it's a big responsibility i like
what gabriel was doing yeah but it was
weird because nobody was looking at it
i saw you guys somewhere i think it was
an irvine with felicia
and i go you know what nobody has
mentioned about this
that this has a kind of survive to it
like gabriel would do you know you it
would it would take you 40 minutes till
you got to see gabriel
and there was four guys doing 10 minutes
a piece
for them with different [ __ ] views
it was interesting you know and then
somebody uh was talking to me somebody
from the church
recently about no not maybe in utah
they asked me if i had seen gabriel's
move or they went to see gabriel he had
a half time during his show yeah
intermission there was another mission
and yeah it was [ __ ] amazing it was
just uh it was an event
it is an event it still is an event i
mean i shouldn't say it wasn't even it
still isn't even so you get to learn it
all yeah you see it becomes it becomes
you know i mean
it when you went to one of the concerts
it was that it was a concert it was
really a [ __ ] it wasn't a stand-up
show it was
you go home and you scratch your head
you're like i gotta re-evaluate
what the [ __ ] i'm doing because that was
magical it was magical it was bad and i
said those are the words that i've used
to to describe it to gabriel but we've
seen a lot of magic a lot of magical
[ __ ] but the beauty of it is bro that
one day you say you know what
i don't even want what gabriel has i
don't even want what joe rogan has it's
a lot of responsibility i just want to
go out
and do my own thing i've been in this
town long enough i want to headline i
got the chops i've got the credits
and that's what you're doing right now
you're in the process of uh
you were telling me you're doing like an
unspoken [ __ ]
oh it's [ __ ] crazy
now let me just add to this
because this to me is one of the most
if i gotta cut if i got
i think one time you won the podcast and
i touched on it
but if i have to go through the top 10
nights i've had
in my 20 years in los angeles
you know when we first get into comedy
we're very fortunate
nobody calls me for those anymore not
that i'd want to do because you're busy
you're doing the podcast
but there was a time where you would get
your phone ring every [ __ ] day
that somebody would have a bar and uh
somewhere yeah we're doing comedy that
night and you would get 30 bucks
and a meal yeah jesus 30 bucks
on a couple of drink tickets let me ask
you something can you get me out of that
by 9 45
cause i gotta be at the comedy store by
10 30 tell me the truth or don't
[ __ ] me dog is there a dodger game
[ __ ] tell me the truth i'm saying
because i got other spots
and it was and you went down there you
got to see different comics and
i don't have that in my life no more
like that that's gone but there was a
time when marilyn and maryland would
call me twice a week marilyn was the
king of the hustle
say whatever you want about maryland god
rest herself she would call me joey
martine moreno's book in a room and
whatever he wants to know if you'll take
that down
for 20 minutes
dave will drive i'm like [ __ ] it
those are the fun [ __ ] days
god rest aside it's going to be your
anniversary 10 years
can i tell you that that um
i you know you meet a lot of people you
meet a lot of [ __ ] people
and you know
out of a lot of a lot of people that i
know
no one reaches out as consistently
to say hey how are you
i [ __ ] love you like you know because
we don't hang out all the time no no no
we don't hang out a bunch
we we we we see each other rarely you
know um but but
i dude you we you check in and and you
actually genuinely you always have since
i met you you've you've never stopped
checking and saying hey i'm just
checking to see how you're doing there's
not too many genuine people you meet you
know and that and but but marilyn would
do the same thing
yeah which is checked with this family
dude and it was it was
all about like just part of it you know
i always felt like holy [ __ ] you guys
you guys are
what a real deal real [ __ ] yeah
yeah but it's funny i go to this [ __ ]
bar i had met you maybe twice or three
times before this
and uh we're doing the show i'm a blast
i think maryland's up before me
you're on stage and all of a sudden
there's a commotion i don't know what
the [ __ ] it is
and i go marilyn what's going on she
goes oh my god martina's going outside
to fight this guy i go what are you
talking about he was just on stage
and he goes he's going outside because i
guess he said something about the
president the guy's the soldier
or something [ __ ] crazy and they got
to pull up politics
then like 10 minutes later
it was the next comic you were hosting
you went up there your shirt was torn a
little bit he had a couple smacks in his
mouth
and you went back on stage and did the
comedy
and now you were friends
like you bought him a shot something
weird had happened martina it was it was
it was just a [ __ ] like you just you
reason with somebody you know when you
just like tell somebody like you know
when you get to that point where you
can't just [ __ ] like look you [ __ ]
you know it doesn't get more basic than
this when you take it to that level with
somebody no but you you went outside you
came back in like a gentleman
brought me up on stage
that was um
that was rick ramos's room and bro
yeah it was ramos's room in our house
but it had to be maryland's dead 10
years this november wow so this had to
be what 15 years ago wow
15 years ago i put it at 2002 [ __ ] yes
yes
that's why i fell in love with you when
you went you threw a couple punches and
you came back looking like a gentleman
when i left you guys were having a beer
everybody was happy somebody was missing
the tooth
but it didn't matter
it all happened for the namesake and
comedy but now
you're out there
and i see your little [ __ ] facebook
videos and you're at a mexican
restaurant
in chicago and i admire that you know
when you're out there
you get the opportunity to do this you
know until
fluffy starts his next tour
and uh
whatever it feels great for you i'm
happy you're doing this you have a
website you should
yeah has your dates
what's that you have a website which has
all your yeah yeah um actually my date's
on eventbrite right now eventbrite yup
martin moreno and what's up and what
gigs do you have coming up uh [ __ ] bro
this right now this uh
friday the 7th
magicopolis is a freaking theater in
santa monica dog right around the corner
from the promenade okay it's uh so it's
uh
it's just a pretty cool ass theater they
do uh this they do magic and [ __ ] but
[ __ ] it's uh it's [ __ ] sick bro
it's perfect for what the [ __ ] i'm doing
jerry must have been there for all those
oh dude oh dude listen let me tell you
something
do i want another star yeah
you know what
there's no way in [ __ ] like when you
call yourself a savage
there's a lot of people that say [ __ ]
savage and they just throw that [ __ ] out
there you [ __ ] are savages
no [ __ ]
[Applause]
fried crackers
no you don't even find crackers you're
not gonna eat two [ __ ] stars
look at this we got a better man
we'll finish this out lee
no we're not
me and you
like [ __ ] gentlemen we'll finish out
what's in this bag no no that's what
we'll do come here no don't tell me
[ __ ] no
so help me god i'll tie you up and i'll
leave you in here for three days
how much is this one i would say not for
you i'll never give you two and a minute
okay good thank you you're gonna need a
half of 125. what are we doing that's
what i'm saying i'm not no we had we had
20 50 already well listen how are you
working with him the high was
what was your high your highway 3 000.
that's enough okay so wait i'm only so
that would only put me at three percent
yeah so what percent is that lee hold on
let me figure it out man okay okay so
i'll do i'll do one more red star how
about that let's not listen
let me ask you a question
what's the difference
between a red star
but can i just do one more one more
already yeah one more purple yellow
promise there's only a couple in here
yet listen there's
there's four let's do two pieces no
that's easy already oh guys you see what
happens he this is like the guy look but
look look look at the fair but look at
this
look
we're done for the week
no we're not we've got plenty more stars
when i lie to you what are you talking
about you're supposed to write
millions these are 125s this is for a
different mission we use it you know we
can't we have to eat 22 125
just to get the party stuff dude you
guys are like rick and morty bro
we got two little stars here
then you go you're gonna see animals at
the [ __ ] at the at the whatever
the zoo no the other place
they started with like 20 friends
and they all got picked you're going to
walk by these little [ __ ]
look how they're looking at you they're
crying
[Laughter]
i'll do one dude where else he going
please please you're not gonna eat two
of them those two came together you know
how we do it here
what's two before and twenty two fifty
is what
i wanted twenty six fifty dude
that's crazy what would you do what
would you do 24.50 all right there you
go thank you
what are you doing i want to watch you
cocksuck i don't trust you what are you
doing trust me
john you want it
wow
let's go
what's the problem here listen
this lap
there you go there you go oh [ __ ]
it's time [ __ ] it's over
it's over we eat that last [ __ ] star
like this like a soldier
[Music]
that's it
[Music]
do you understand that my 125 is just
kicking in hard as [ __ ]
that [ __ ] came in like a swamp like a
[ __ ] wave let me tell you something
that 200 that's from the bottom of the
bag
it's filled up turn that off that's not
the one i'm looking there's no way i
could keep up with you [ __ ] there's
no way i could even dream about it
brother ever i don't want anybody ever
come on this show
and think for one second yeah that they
have to keep up with okay we just want
you to come on the show good have a good
time get stoned
get some water and that's it do a bomb
to the tube
music
2015 we're getting back what belongs to
us and that's it no more [ __ ] around
play the national anthem lee i'm sick of
these [ __ ] let's go the good
one too with shoots and [ __ ] people
missing legs i want to hit a good one
lisa yeah the ball's in your [ __ ]
court no more [ __ ] around you want
your life to be better i can't help you
lee can't help you joe rogan can't help
you ari can't help you god can't [ __ ]
help you only you can [ __ ] help you
grab your [ __ ] balls get a [ __ ]
notebook and write down what the [ __ ]
you're gonna do this year and this is it
you're not gonna have these problems
[ __ ] the drugs [ __ ] the cigarettes [ __ ]
that dumb [ __ ] it all starts [ __ ]
today all right no more [ __ ] excuses
that's the [ __ ] this is the year of
the [ __ ] soldier it's 2015.
we're going in like [ __ ] marines you
understand me welcome to church
[ __ ]
[Music]
you